ubisoft has a pretty fun operators vs
aliens game and rainbow six extraction
it's an expanded version of the limited
time mode players experienced three
years ago but it has a slightly more
honed roster of operators gadgets and
abilities
there's a need for this game to prove to
fans that it's a standalone title and
after a few hours of playing on the
alaska map
it still feels like this should exist in
a shared experience and rewards
ecosystem with rainbow six
siege we're not sure if that's gonna
happen in this video we're gonna get
into the details of our play session and
how the game works to keep up on the
details of extraction and all the other
shooters
being announced at e3 make sure to give
us the old thumbs up and subscribe to
the channel
when it comes to the draw of extraction
as a standalone game we need to talk
about the difficulty and how that might
hook players into a leveling system that
then lets them tackle tougher and
tougher challenges
one thing i should say is that we played
this demo on moderate difficulty with
plenty of gear and weapons unlocked
so we didn't really get a sense of how
progress feels that seems kind of
crucial for a complete understanding of
this game
on the moderate settings with
suppressors we just quickly dropped
stealth and shot our way through
missions
i can't tell if you brought your a game
or this is too easy for you
the game mechanics seem designed for
things to be difficult health isn't that
common and damage stays with you between
rounds
pickup resources are shared between the
one to three players and it's pretty
important to keep track of who needs
help the most
let's get to you one selfish player
could gobble up resources and leave your
team in a bad spot
the aliens did hit hard when they got
close but that rarely happened
this game might be very different
without unlocked characters mainly it
should be a lot harder which is a good
thing because you need a lot more
strategy in planning
so for assuming that this game is more
difficult at launch then the draw is
earning
xp to unlock react gear and explosives
you'll be familiar with react explosives
as far as we can tell the only one that
does something
drastically different than in rainbow
six siege are smoke grenades which now
drive aliens out of cover otherwise it's
the standard fare of claymores impact
grenades frags and stuns react gear has
the potential to help players out at
higher threat settings
but it mostly boils down to more ammo
more explosives
armor or a recon drone it feels like
this category needs a bit more
creative thought most players will
naturally gravitate towards the armor
which seems to have the most benefits by
reducing damage and keeping players from
quickly dying when they go down
having the drone be a choice and not a
default probably means it'll rarely get
picked unless you're doing some kind of
mandatory stealth objective
but even then you can just pick vigil
who cloaks and can easily take on
stealth objectives without having to
sacrifice some other gear for the drone
as this game is further developed it'd
be good to see some less standard and
more creative options in the gear
category
two extractions credit directional sound
design is very good and you don't really
need a drone to understand what's around
you maps are full of nests sprawl and
different alien types you battle while
chasing objectives
we played the game on incursion mode
which has up to three sub maps you can
tackle by going through airlocks and
restarting a 15 minute timer
you can extract it anytime but the more
sub maps you tackle the better the xp
gets
objectives are randomly chosen from a
pretty huge list with the exception of
rescue teammate which automatically
triggers if someone goes down and is
captured
one funny thing to note is that the
extraction refers to you extracting your
own dead
characters if you successfully extract
the dead player they come back the next
round with less health you can also just
leave that operator captured
and choose another one that you have
unlocked air locks that transition
between submaps also have a bit of a
catch in that if you're not there when
your team triggers one there's a
countdown
and if you don't make that your
character gets automatically captured
the alaska map is fairly open
and diffuse which can be good or bad
it's kind of awesome getting immersed in
an alien infested zone
but it also means there's not a lot to
decide when going between objectives
aliens do seem to be able to breach
rooms and one of the most fun objectives
we played sabotage felt like a round of
siege there was a bomb plant a prep
phase and then entry by the aliens
alibis decoys were absolutely clutch in
distracting enemies
several of the objectives like
triangulation where you need to turn on
a series of laptops in a specific order
and rescue where you pull a vip out of a
goo pillar while your team shoots
tentacles require coordination
it's gonna be best to do these
activities on mic because the tools
geared towards players with randos
seems to be limited to a ping and also a
three second countdown emote that might
not be enough to tell people
specifically what you need them to do
the communication wheel is good enough
though for basic asks like
telling doc you need health i'm in a bad
way here
when it comes to operators there are two
things to cover first the story is a
direct continuation of the new mexico
event
and investigating the source of the
threat is still a big part of the game
in the original seeing operators and
cutscenes outside of siege is something
i really enjoyed
when it comes to how operators play
understandably one of the larger
challenges of the first limited time
mode was
how to fit their guns and gear designed
largely for pvp
into a pve setting in the old version
not everything was useful but some
operators really did shine in ways they
didn't even in pvp
like tychunka extraction has the
advantage of designing the entire game
around a select roster of operators
but at moderate difficulty we ran into
similar issues as the original where
some of them like alibi
who could distract aliens really shined
and others like sledge didn't seem to
have a clear purpose
he can still bash through walls but
almost every destructible wall just had
a door next to it habana can open up
strips of heavy barricades as usual but
this skill is largely designed for
attacking rooms and
never really came in handy her launcher
can also apparently bypass certain
enemies armor
dock was still pretty essential for
handing out health the roster so far is
doc pulse ella alibi habana
lion vigil sledge and finca the game's
in development so operators may change
over time or have specific uses we just
didn't see
as part of the embargo i need to tell
you that we played the game remotely
using parsec but nothing i've mentioned
about it would be impacted
we're not talking about graphics or bugs
or glitches in an unfinished game
overall extraction feels like about what
you'd expect from an evolution of the
siege outbreak limited time
mode it'll be interesting to see how
story elements are brought in and
whether the game will wind up sharing
progress with siege
that'd be a huge draw for the pve player
base at minimum to come in and grind for
experience or weapon unlocks
operators maps and the challenge could
change quite a lot before this game is
released
remember our experience was playing on
one map at a single difficulty with
plenty of gear
e3 2021 is in full swing and we're
covering a ton of game announcements
with our play for all event so make sure
to subscribe to gamespot's youtube
channel
to learn more about your favorite
upcoming games i'll stop talking now and
you can just see how extraction plays a
bit
thanks for watching don't let the ark
cells reach the arc tree
the parasite is retaliating get our
casualty out of there
no more anchor points pull our operator
out
keep at it the archery is letting go
set the operator down in the extraction
pod
that operator will be grateful for what
you did today knock
i'm dry
will open
cease fire
good
[Music]
deploying sensor
i'm reloading
not a nest left time for a sample
drop that order
yes a react scientist can work with this
there's a recharge here
you